Ouais, y a du changement pour euh. Les immigrés,
les sans-papiers en France.
Voilà,
euh, à l'occasion du de l'examen de la nouvelle loi,
le projet de loi sur l'immigration,
alors euh, y a déjà des choses qui
qui ont été votées par le. Par le Sénat, hein,
euh, ça concerne donc les.
Les immigrés sans papiers qui résident en France.
Alors euh, il y a la suppression de la M E,
alors l'aide médicale d'État,
donc ils auront plus le droit euh
aux soins, donc la la suppression de l'IME pour les
les sans-papiers
et alors elle sera remplacée par euh. L'ONU,
l'aide médicale d'urgence,
c'est c'est-à-dire que ça donne des des droits
1 peu plus restreints,
mais ça n'empêche pas les soins quand-même.
Euh pour pas qu'il y ait de
d'épidémie de maladie, ramener de pays euh.
Étranger, et c'est 1 mesure d'hygiène.
Voilà. Donc euh, l'aïm
est transformé en aymut
pour les sans-papiers.